ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الفلسطينيه ان موسطنين
اسرائيليين اقتحموا بدات كفر الديك في
سلفيت في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وحطموا
سيارات المواطنين الفلسطينيين بتزامن مع
اغلاقه جيش الاحتلال مداخل البلده
ومن جانب اخر قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
عثر على اثار تسلل
داخل مستوطنه بيتارليت غرب بيت لحم وقد
دوت سفارات الانذار في المستوطنه بعد
العثور على حقيبه فيها عبوه ناسفه داخل
حافله داخله المستوطنه وحصد وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه فان مواطنا فلسطيني ترك
الحقيبه داخل الحافله وترجل منها قبل
دخولها المستوطنات المذكوره وان السلطات
الجيش اكتشفتها ونجحت في ابطال مفعولها
بينما منزل معتزل خواجه منافذ عمليه تل
ابيب في قريه نيالين غربه رام الله تنظم
الى مراسله جزيره جيفارا البديري والمزيد
من التفاصيل جيفارا
قوات الاحتلال سحبت هذا اليوم من
القريه قريه نيعلين ولكن قبل ان تقوم
بالانسحاب قامت وحده الهندسه التابعه
لسلطات الاحتلال باخذ مقاسات منزل عائله
معتز الخواجه الشابه الذي اتهم بتنفيذ
عمليه
ليله امس في قلبي تل ابيب البيت يقع في
الطابق الثاني من هذه البنايه السكنيه
التي يقطنها عدد اخر من افراد العائله
الاعمام وغيرهم ولكن البيت في الطابق
الثاني عندما يتم اخذ هذه المقاسات معناه
انه قد يكون عندما يتم وتتم عمليه
التفجير او هدم المنزل لا يمكن
القيام بكل البنايه بعمليه التفجير فقط
يتم هناك عمليه تفجير داخل
الطابق الثاني بالطبع العائله اكدت ان
قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت والد وشقيق معتز
الخواجه ولكن خلال عمليه اقتحام المنزل
واعتقال والد وشقيق معتز اندلعت مواجهات
الذين خرجوا للتصدي لجنود الاحتلال نعم
اذا كما ذكرت لك اندلعت مواجهات فجر هذا
اليوم اصيب فيها شابان بالقدم بالرصاص
الحي الذي اطلقه جنود الاحتلال وعشرات
الشبان بحالات اختناق حتى في داخل منازل
العائلات ولكن ايضا ما جاءنا قبل قليل
وتاكد من وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الشاب
عبد الكريم الشيخ قام مستوطن اسرائيلي
بقتله صباح هذا اليوم قربه مستوطنه مع
علاء شمران شرقي قلقيليه وزعما المستوطن
المسلح بان الشاب عبد الكريم والبالغ من
العمر 21 عاما اقترب منه وهو من المستوطن
وهو مزارع وزعم انه كان يحمل سكين وعدد من
العبوات اليدويه فقام باطلاق النار عليه
على الفور بالطبع كانت الروايه غير
مثبته لانها وقت وفقه الروايه الاسرائيليه
الان تم ابلاغ وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه من
قبل الارتباط المدني الفلسطيني باستشهاد
الشاب عبد الكريم الشيخ والبالغ كما ذكرنا
من العمر واحد وعشرين عاما وبهذا العدد
يرتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه
العام اي في اقل من شهرين ونصف الى ثمانين
شهيدا في كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه بالطبع
الان التوتر الحذر يسود كافه ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه خاصه ايضا وان قوات الاحتلال عززت
من تواجدها بعد عمليه تل ابيب ليله امس
كما عززت من التواجد الامني والعسكري
والشرطي في كل انحاء اسرائيل اخشى من قيام
شبان بعمليات اخرى وهذه عاده ما تحدث
عاقبه اي عمليه ولكن فقط نذكر هنا ان
عمليه الامن عمليه الامس في تل ابيب كانت
العمليه الثانيه بعد حواره التي يتبناها
فصيل فلسطيني وهي حركه حماس ولكن قبل ذلك
كان هناك عشرات العمليات التي نفذها شبان
فلسطينيين بشكل فردي اشكرك الجزيره وكنت
معنا امام منزل معتزل الخواجه مراكز تل
ابيب في قريه ناللين غربا رام الله